a medida que pasan las horas la
distancia entre el mp lea el partido
presidencial y el opositor unidad se
reduce pero tras el de recuento del 97%
de los votos el antiguo partido único de
angola mantiene su ventaja wendel ángel
m pelea tiene un total de 51 07 por
ciento de los votos lo que en términos
de mandatos equivale a 124 diputados
unita obtiene el 44 05 por ciento de los
votos lo que le da la posibilidad de
tener 90 diputados
estas elecciones han sido las más
reñidas de la historia del país el mp l
a está acostumbrado a ganar las
elecciones legislativas sin problemas
pero la llegada del carismático alberto
costa júnior a la cabeza de unita el
principal partido de la oposición ha
barajado las cartas su movimiento seguía
por el momento a reconocer su derrota
el anuncio de estos resultados parciales
se hace sin ningún tipo de detalle lo
que supone una clara violación de la ley
electoral
para ver tu costa juniors ha tenido
éxito a la hora de ganarse a los jóvenes
del país que se enfrentan a la alta
inflación al desempleo y al elevado
coste de la vida
los 500.000 empleos prometidos son
mentira no tenemos nada los jóvenes
quieren un cambio ya estamos hartos del
bla bla bla y de las mentiras
de
los jóvenes no podemos aguantar más no
trabajamos no tenemos nada no comemos es
más sufrimiento que otra cosa
angola es el segundo productor de
petróleo del áfrica subshariana y uno de
los principales productores de diamantes
del mundo pero la pobreza sigue siendo
galopante en 2020 en casi 1 de cada 2
angoleños vivían con menos de 2 dólares
al día